TREY: WELCOME BACK TO
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA."
APOLOGIES TO ANYONE WHO TOOK
SERIOUSLY PRESIDENT BIDEN
COMMISSION TO STUDY THE
COURT.
THIS COMMISSION -- COURT.
SUPREME COURT.
IT WAS BORN OF POLITICAL
CONVENIENCE.
THEY WANTED TO DILUTE WHAT
THEY BELIEVED TO BE A
CONSERVATIVE MAJORITY.
BY ADDING MORE PROGRESSIVE
JUSTICES.
THEY WANTED TO GET POLITICS
OUT OF THE SUPREME COURT BY
ADDING MORE POLITICAL
JUSTICES.
IT WAS AND REMAINS A
TERRIBLE IDEA.
BUT MODERN POLITICAL LEADERS
ARE TOO AFRAID OF THE BASE
TO DISAGREE WITH THE BASE.
BIDEN DIDN'T WANT TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION ON PACKING THE
COURT DURING THE CAMPAIGN,
HE PUNTED, SAID HE WOULD
FORM A COMMISSION.
THE COMMISSION NOW HAS SOME
MODEST PROPOSALS, NONE OF
WHICH WILL EVER BE ENACTED.
I DO HAVE SOME IDEAS OF MY
OWN TO REPUBLICANS THINK
ABOUT FOLLOWING JUSTICES,
BRENNAN, BLACK MAN,
STEPHENS, WARN AND SUITOR,
ALL WERE LIBERAL MEMBERS OF
THE COURT PUT ON THE BENCH
BY REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTS.
MY ADVICE TO REPUBLICANS TO
DO A BETTER JOB OF VETTING
THE JUDICIAL --
PHILOSOPHY OF NOMINEES
BEFORE YOU ELEVATE THEM TO
THE HIGH COURT.
TO CONTRARY CAN YOU NAME A
SINGLE JUSTICE PUT ON A
SUPREME COURT DURING YOUR
LIFETIME BY A DEMOCRAT
PRESIDENT WHO SURPRISED YOU
WITH HIS OR HER
CONSERVATISM.
TO MEDIA JUST TRY TO AT
LEAST MAKE -- FAKE BEING
FAIR.
IT TREATS SERIOUS AND
COMPLEX LEGAL ISSUES WITH A
PROVOCATIVE HEADLINE AND A
TWEET, ACCORDING TO MEDIA
CONSERVATIVES JUST WANT TO
RESTRICT AND DENY AND LIMIT
WHILE LIBERAL JUDGES, THAT I
THEY EXPANDING AND
EMPOWER AND LIBERATE.
THE WORDS THEY USE PROVE
THEIR BIAS, AND THEIR BIAS
EXPLAINS THEIR DIMINISHED
ROLE IN OUR COUNTRY AND
DIMINISHED VIEW OF THE COURT
BY THE PUBLIC.
TO US, WHAT DO WE WANT FROM
THE COURT?
DO WE VICE PRESIDENT
FAIRNESS OR -- DOE WE WANT
FAIRNESS OR JUST A DECISION
WE AGREE WITH?
CAN WE SEPARATE WHAT THE LAW
IS, FROM WHAT WE WANT IT TO
BE?
DO WE HAVE THE DISCIPLINE TO
WIN THE DEBATE OR DO WE JUST
WANT TO WIN THE SUPREME
COURT VOTE?
WE DON'T NEED MORE OR FEWER
JUSTICES, WE DON'T NEED TO
SET THEIR DOCKET OR THEIR
RETIREMENT DECISIONS, WE
NEED A COURT THAT
UNDERSTANDS ITS ROLE IN OUR
TRI-PART TIGHT SYSTEM,
JUSTICE.
>> WE NEED TO ELEVATE THE
VIRTUE OF FAI